citizens of the reject Nation ah I got
my two Jews with me today who both had
weird birthday weeks as well oh and they
don't know each other that well
whatsoever my hands are sweaty it's all
good you're welcome but you guys will
find a lot of commonality with this
movie that actually boomed the real
reject so you guys better love it
regardless of whatever opinions I'm
talking to you Jew number one you're Jew
number two today I'm je one apparently
hey first the worst second the best okay
I'll take it okay third is the one with
a hairy
chest this is going to be good I I'll
let you guys get to it Roxy you're here
more you enter the video okay um here's
my mouse and here's my poster oh wait
this isn't room
Raiders it's the
raid yes I love it we're here to watch
the Raid a movie that literally every
film nerd references that I have never
seen is this your type of movie oh yeah
I mean I was a DI hard fan of the
Daredevil Netflix show and from the
hallway scenes everyone always Compares
it to the raid so I'm like I got to see
you can't say die hard and then the raid
you know they're often compared just got
to be like a super fan of the raid I
understood that reference oh yeah cuz
I'm very very clever you know who's
clever prepper thank you for editing all
of our videos cleverly we really
appreciate you guys and thank you to you
for going over to patreon to watch our
full length watch along you can sync up
with us you super B sex and rejects Greg
and John cover several shows exclusively
over there with highlights and watch
alongs
include did gr you can't stand and laugh
at me alongside you just can't I thought
that was solid I'm pretty sure I nailed
it we're about to raid this raid we're
going to raid the raid I'm down to raid
the raid too let's do it no not raid to
just the raid one I was me meant as well
but yes all right I'll give you
Redemption during the
movie
[Music]
you
R you're just full of puns Roxy
yeah yes this is me at the gym every
time I've always wanted to be able to do
one of those you got to start on the
Gravitron M machines and then you work
your way up to the real thing I don't
know the word you just used it's a
machine where you can decrease weight
from your body weight saying I have too
much weight yes that's exactly what I
was saying you read it
correctly these movies always tend to
have like those crazy audio pops
yeah
D it's kind of like is the itman intro
with the yeah yeah no I was thinking
that where he does the super fast move
called something clearly we're well
versed in martial arts yeah we know our
martial arts very
well the sound designer is really
good Stakes are immediately higher cuz
she's
pagers that's a very concise baby
BM
all right I'll bring him back yeah it's
like some kind of mission he's got to go
on it's the new I'll be back I'll bring
him back that almost did sound like The
Terminator theme right there too as you
say that it's interesting to have your
first movie be called Redemption usually
I feel like that comes later that'd be
the second or third film
yeah
oh these subtitles are going so fast I'm
so
slow I want to see him tear down walls
the other's
Andy
these are them I think so let's go ramen
noodles that's how you know they're
really dangerous when they're eating
ramen noodles I guess that was the most
dangerous in college then every day
twice a day ramen noodles are pretty
bomb not GNA
lie oh no oh he's gone he's dead
bummer damn
oh it's like it man and John Wick had a
baby I hope that there's a bullet in
there and he takes it and he kills him
God the suspense of waiting oh
no the hammer is worse there's a scene
from Casino have you seen that yeah oh
the H to the hand
oh oh oh
boy they're introducing us to a lot of
characters really
fast all right let's do it yeah the
music is killer in this so far I think
if they just take away the ramen noodles
he'll be defenseless against them who
are you focusing on right now everybody
I just want to make sure the main guy
who's got the baby at home yeah he surv
that's your dude obviously like everyone
to survive but yeah specifically him in
the subtitle his name is
Rama oh they're
newbies this is a good first test in
this situation new recruits or whatnot
his team why is this guy in no helmet
like is your head safe he's like I'm so
good I don't need a helmet yeah don't
get cocky though you get killed that was
your opportunity to have a little Han
Solo don't get cocky I was thinking more
I'm not cocky I'm confident so when you
tell me I'm the best it's a
compliment the CP is working too
go very Bleak even when you're armed to
the teeth like that just in general it's
got to be so terrifying to go in these
types of situations if you I would think
it'd be more terrifying even if you are
dressed up as a
badass you know I've watched this in
years from movies I've never been able
to get my I'm pretty good at this oh are
you yeah okay allegedly
allegedly so they're going to walk in
and find all these dead
bodies on the
ground that wouldn't surprise me that's
your interpretation of where we are
though I wouldn't even be shocked if he
has some inside guys on the
team a does this man deserved to
die
ah cool shot I love the way he came out
of the Shadows like that it's like
batman-esque
you don't hear
them good cop bad cop yeah well he can
also sympathize with him is he a wife
only people with wives can sympathize
yeah exactly anyone else has no Humanity
in
them I'm really loving the
cinematography so far that's funny I was
just thinking about the score ah well
that too is
badass but where is the
ramen
he crapped
himself are you fully understanding why
they're taking these
prisoners I think they're they
just they work for the main guy well I
think they said earlier in the movie
he's letting a bunch of druggies and low
life pushers and all that
yeah he's gonna run bummer
SC oh no no don't shoot
him
bummer oh he's going to get killed right
now oh what a
shot
damn well didn't help the situation
because he got it he got to tell them it
was police if you're going to shoot him
you needed to shoot him earlier not that
I'm advocating for shooting children
early yeah
yeah all right this kid needs to
unfreeze I mean after watching I would
assume it's his brother or friend get
shot like I could understand his
apprehension to not stay
still
yeah wow homie doesn't give an f yeah
he's not worried those are the scariest
type of
villains this is giving me some dread
Vibes I haven't seen it ah it's a great
film you should insert comment here Roxy
hasn't seem dread that needs to be the
next one I
agree what cool architecture
yeah oh snipers yeah oh oh damn that's
like a sniper's dream
hole glory
hole that's interesting not showing it
but letting us hear the
screams well they're letting everybody
else hear the screams yeah yeah
yeah oh
damn
oh the
eyeball no no no are you an idiot I get
that you're sad but are you an
idiot oh snake is quite the
Escape
yeah
yeah jeez this is so
tense but you're sitting there what do
you do
duck yeah I wouldn't know how to react
in that
situation you know that shot reminds me
of Robocop when Mr Kenny got from Ed 209
just got blown to
bits oh the gun behind him oh [__]
ooh a feeling it's only going to be like
one or two cops left at by the end
yeah it's going to be the main two dudes
right I would assume so be my guess and
maybe the non-helmet guy yeah but he's
the first one that shot the kid he
doesn't deserve to be any of the main
he's not going to live through the movie
but he might live through the
scene
[Music]
creepy wow that's quite the proposition
free rent get rid of the insects they
should just get some raid to get rid of
the insects
raid
no you can't honey
what
yeah
why what is it like a not sanctioned
maybe yeah it's my guess where he
doesn't trust the rest of the police
department yeah
nobody that was not
wise H are they military or are they
they were cops I thought they were cops
clearly that dude has never seen any
movies cuz you never not let other
people know about the mission
yeah oh damn I think we're in
trouble the score is like one of the
greatest scores that I've heard in a
long time it really builds suspense and
tension
wait oh God
o oh what do you
[Music]
whoa ooh Shadow shot y'all are screwed
City oh no no helmet dude where is your
helmet they want their free rent yeah
listen I get a la rent oh it's too high
it's crazy I wouldn't kill for it but
probably getting a bar fight or
something yeah yeah
yeah burn them with the
trucks
wonder if it's like a personal mission
for the guy who doesn't have a helmet
because why wouldn't he like
let the rest of the department know that
they're doing this
right oh boy does he see him I think he
does but they're like in a no win
situation right
now
[Music]
woo movie is obviously called called The
Raid do you think this entire thing is
about the raid of this one place I it
has to be you think we're here the whole
time the whole movie I would
guess my how the tables have turned they
went to raid the place and now they're
worried about getting
raided all the people near the Windows
like
got to be a trapo around here somewhere
any looking for any exit he's smart yeah
I love how resourceful he
is yeah that's it that's it look under
the
rug like all these pull-ups were not for
nothing do you think there are monitors
in this room felt like they were more in
the corridors and the hallways I don't
know if he had them actually in rooms
but you never know he owns the place
so can somebody go help him try to bang
down this floor feels like it' be a good
use of your
resources oh
wow wait
Jack's got to survive so we got to help
him wow that was a cool tracking
shot oh my
God this is
intense o o
o that
pickaxe woo
that's a nice
tackle
oh how many of us do you think are left
how many what the cops oh I think
there's only a
couple oh no oh
no damn shoot his ear
off
the sound design is I just can't stop
talking about it I know it's it's so
good
oh what is he making like a bomb oh he's
trying to make it heavier if they shoot
at it it'll explode I don't know or
maybe he's just making it heavier to
keep the thing close or oh yeah I guess
yeah
damn
yeah won't penetrate through
the oh oh yeah there we
go I was
sick going to say they also could have
exploded the place jumped into the
fridge like Indiana
Jones
he's way too chill but an evil F telling
you it's the villains who are the most
cist are the ones who scare me the most
because you know there's rage penting up
in
there yeah I wonder what the backstory
with him and no helmet guy is yeah oh my
God oh God the makeup in this film is
insane
ooh like I'll put you out your
misery oh the ear
yeah how do you keep calm when you're in
so much pain pain I
know and you can't hear it's probably
that ringing sound or no I don't know
actually what it is it's a probably a
combination of pain and
ring this score is so good don't take my
line hey it's Hollywood we steal here
you're only allowed to care about the
cinematography and I'm only allowed to
care about the sound of hey talk to
Steph I get I say who what music is good
ask her she'll tell
you you see a hand you take it I
mean damn that was wild shot almost
looks like he was like a hologram in the
tour this is so
intense I would not want to be the
cleanup crew for this right yeah it's
got to be free rent or I don't clean
this
up this guy just put on a hockey mask he
could be like Jason
Vorhees that's my guy oh this one
yeah
oh
wonder if he's ever been in a dire
situation as this one the actor no no no
I just meant the the yeah the actor yes
you mean like what were these characters
up to before this what's the prequel
yeah I want to see the
prequel you think a lot of bullets are
out you think they're just tapped I mean
yeah they fired a
lot
wait wait
wait what you build all that suspense
and then cut to another that's
interesting
choice
oh yes
oh oh my God this dude's such a bad
ass yeah he's dope he's got something
worth fighting for you know
yeah I like how everybody who comes
after him has to make a big sound before
they come so it's like well it's like
tennis you got to make big sounds before
you hit the ball
totally
jeez oh my God
the the choreography the
cinematography that's giving me some
Daredevil Netflix Vibes maybe they took
it from that
[Music]
this
for lack of better words it's cool that
we started with guns because yeah then
like we escalated to this which those
were amazing but this is even better
better yeah exactly the hand toand
choreography is so good sometimes it
gets too repetitive in a movie and this
is like every different floors different
levels different layers yeah it's funny
you say that cuz as the gunfighting was
going I'm like I hope we get a lot of
hand toand choreography now I got to
imagine too the main villain Tom I
believe his name is if he's watching
this on surveillance I'd want to recruit
this guy but like leave him alive I want
him on my our
team
intens you don't want to get shot with
your own gun yeah it's okay if you get
shot with someone else else's but not
your
own okay so I believe there's five left
are you counting him that guy you mean
yeah yeah well I guess four and a half
oh we can't stand so it's good four and
a
quarter yeah oh you got one and you
threw it I was going to say you should
maybe still save that one still a bullet
a bullet yeah what he's like dude I got
these these are my guns I feel like that
bullet's going to come back to haunt
him it's
whoever's oh the wife if this film did
come out before dread which I assume it
did like they really took a lot from
dread took a lot from this what year was
dread 2012 I don't know what year this
think this was 2011 okay not positive
though they took a lot from it which is
fine I
mean
oh hide them
oh that's quite the trap
door I'll bleed
you got scary eyes yeah he does and he
barely
blinks
me too I hate
liars oh my God that is such a cool
shot sir what are we going to watch for
TV tonight thank
you oh my this feels like a horror film
now
he's going to come back with blood on
yeah he's gonna say is he going to
notice blood on his
machete hey dude wipe the blood off that
thing that's what I was just thinking
cuz that guy will for sure notice
that I don't want to see
it ah ah
ah
oh yeah he's going to notice the blood
he's trying to clean it did he yeah and
the wall you have to be so mentally
tough to not squirm or make a noise when
being even a little bit sliced by a
machete in the
face oh what that bullet I think
so
the level of pain that man is feeling
from there and there I I
yeah what you got going on is he going
to take these two guys out because he
wanted to do it
alone oh wow why cuz then he gets a
better deal or maybe to prove himself
that he can do by
himself he said
why was going to be so graic remember he
said to the guy Tama he was like why are
you doing this so maybe he's on their
team maybe he thinks it's bad what
they're doing either that or he just
wants to prove he can do by himself I
don't think so cuz he was not happy with
Tama oh yeah cuz he kept saying like
they're going to call reinforcements
right right
right T feels like the more dangerous
version of the monkey in Toy Story 3
that was watching all them on
surveillance from Escape in daycare your
references are wild I know right that's
what I've been
told oh no oh it's on like Donkey
Kong take his weapon you need something
cuz you threw away the the one bullet
[Applause]
yeah oh boy
oh who jeez but grab the
weapon and probably also not to get in
trouble right yeah combo of
both
whoa
Jesus that would be the most
uncomfortable
death oh my
god oh he's the man bro yeah badass
status like if I look up badass in the
dictionary there's going to be a picture
of
him
uh out the window you go oh he goes with
[Music]
them use him as a
shield oh no this dude is built like a
brick wall what did you just come into
though look
around excuse
me the
sky all right back together back
together no no we're on the same side oh
it's the guy that you that you said he
took cut the two in the elevator they
know each other they're Brothers I don't
know I you could be
R yeah yep he deserves
that my man I can see why
now don't be careful nope keep it going
yep yeah I was going to say in this
situation it's like what
yep yep lean in tell
him
yep
y answer him be wise wear a
helmet clearly he has some but let's go
get our men
uh oh uh oh uh oh knew it
yeah he came out too strong it's like
don't just walk out the door man he's
Jacka he's he can do
anything what is a gun versus
knife is Jacka The Inside
guy
oh that feels like the first unrealistic
moment of the movie compared to the rest
of the movie like I'm happy about it cuz
I want to see them fight but yeah
yeah
who oh that guy's a little
Legend you can see why he's confident
not wanting to shoot
him yeah but still like it's the sure
bet there's no lead up to that at all we
didn't see this guy all the time do that
like oh needed
nose oh you really feel these
punches sound
design what did I tell you it's my thing
stealing your your
lines okay I'm going to need to look at
that face every day so you're going to
have to not beat him up like that cuz
it's my
man you think Jo is gonna die right
now no no no no no no
[Music]
no I hope the old dude comes in and
saves him no helmet dude or just the
main star yeah him too no three
two
a
no really liked him I'm sorry he was my
man I'm done with the
movie
you better hope they don't see him on
surveillance with him he knows where the
surveillance
is their dad yeah okay so they are
brothers I'm brilliant you no one said
you
weren't now we have to survive
dude has no
fear oh the guy is the old guy without
the helmet all
right I'm hopeful to look wait wait look
look look any sign of detection of Life
maybe move your foot move your foot do
it ver Roxy come on Jaa there's no way
right I he broke his neck pretty the way
I unless he's super human I'd be okay
with that pot
twist how do you know
this he blood on his hands from the two
guys he
[Music]
G take the knife for
something no no I knew it I knew the
hand I need a hand I need
the this is my kind of party right here
oh yeah
Dr
I want to see a a bag of white powder
like it's just all
over hey is this guy actually doing
something I want to know about him I'm
sure it will be revealed but like what's
up with him and Tama what's your guess
watch their brothers I'm just kid I have
no
idea he must have used to work for the
organization or something but then we
also heard that he's doing it for money
maybe I mean Jaa said someone's trying
to get
rich well it makes the uh production
designer's job a lot easier one location
I don't know that they shot it in one
location this very likely a completely
different place good
point
wow wow that kid has one resilient
father I mean if anyone can survive a
neck snapping it's definitely Chaka in
my opinion that was a good table
scene oh
no here's his
[Music]
brother but this isn't the 15th floor
right oh his brother's getting beat
up you didn't get my refence I got pe's
on my head but don't call me a p head
his name's Andy like Andy milanus
whatever just can't leave a comment if
you got it cuz he likes a fair
fight now actually the other thing makes
this better because are they going two
on one cuz we know he likes a fair fight
so we let him go from the thing his
character makes more sense
too so this is the sidekick that they
said would burn you or whatever it was
remember at the beginning when they were
talking do he had a
bullets we obviously know each other
well and he's s rep playing this game
he's been paying him off I think Tom has
been paying no
helmet
yeah but why did he do it in the first
place why did he have them raid in the
first place you know cuz then he wanted
out but he figured then he couldn't do
it I think he overestimated the the
situation thought that they were going
to be able to take them down
easily
yes
Redemption
o this dude is Savage and
ruthless team work makes the dream I was
just thinking that come on brothers
let's go
Brothers I kind of like this guy he took
out your man I know well I still think
my Man's
Alive oo music's getting
tenser oh no don't do the neck break oh
no Brother come on through come on
through brother brother come through
brother where you at Andy Andy wake up
Andy get up Andy hello oh is he going to
stab him yeah get there quicker baby I
know your hand hurts Andy and I think
probably the rest of your body too yeah
I would say he's in immense pain all
over where's ear guy I think he got his
neck
oh he's going to kill him he saved his
brother's life and then he's going to H
push the thing in his neck still
fighting with it in his neck push the
thing in his night neck more no no no
poor
Andy ah this is the sickest fight this
is like a jail cell fight yeah work
together Brothers rip him apart how is
this dude have any energy to still keep
fighting with that in his
neck oh both his arms oh yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
a yes
yes o rip it right across all right but
mad respect to this guy that was quite
the fight that's what I mean like I
don't actually like him but got to
respect him that was quite the battle
actually like I don't know if we do have
to respect him it seems like he's done
some really horrible things but I just
meant as a fighter like
damn
right he's got to Die the most painful
death
ever oh okay I'm not getting it he was
going to replace him apparent I think
that's what he's saying but the guys who
sent him yeah but who's razza I think
the guys who are in charge of
him like he's going to shoot him
he's going to shoot him yeah there we
like if my life is over I'm just going
to take you out right now so I think he
was sent in there by a he's a collector
and he was going to either take his
place or get it for the guys who sent
him in but the guys who sent him
actually wanted him dead and called to
give the heads up yeah yeah it was a
setup from the beginning he but did we
meet Reza I don't think so I think he's
shoot himself yeah I think so but maybe
they stop him or maybe there's no
bullet
[Music]
like s's in charge
now the guy with the ears probably like
what y'all know each other or what like
dude the whole point of the mission was
to get your brother and he's not coming
with you ah that sucks they already knew
they needed a raid too
[Music]
I really feel bad for arama though like
again whole motivation was getting his
brother out no I mean I think he also
wanted to do the job it's his job he's a
cop also too I think it wasn't just get
his brother out but he also he knew that
they were going to attack where Andy was
so he's like I got to make sure nothing
happens to him even if I don't get him
out yeah keep him safe yeah okay so I
guess he accomplished one part of his
mission but he did say I'll bring him
home the guy who deserved to die die the
most ends up living I feel like he might
stay or something I mean no he's got a
wife and kid I don't mean to run the
place but do something maybe not he's a
man of Duty yeah you're
right
cut who's the Redemption
for Andy I don't
know
damn that was a really good one yeah oh
I don't think I don't think there was
enough action though what I
mean yeah totally that's definitely it I
mean for of the uh action movies you've
seen in the last decade or so where does
this kind of rank up for you I mean it's
definitely right up there yeah me too um
yeah I've NE I mean it wasn't it it
wasn't
just think we're on to something else
here we just let it ride yeah okay uh it
wasn't it wasn't just that
um the action was Exhilarate I mean it's
just like it was nonstop it was tense to
steal your line the sound design you
felt every punch you felt every bullet
that was being shot and the scoring oh
the score was great it really did a good
J like you already felt the scenes
building up with tension and suspense
just from what was happening visually
but the music like really ramped it up
even more so are two major payoffs were
the fact that they were brothers right
or I guess our reveals the fact that
they're brothers and the fact that uh no
helmet was either going to take over or
whatever it was he was a bad a dirty cop
which we kind of knew the whole time but
we found out more about did both those
land for
you I would say the brother one for sure
the yeah that was definitely a good one
the one with the the cop it was I mean I
was just more invested in the action at
that point that I mean whether that
landed I don't know if that one landed
for me per se it was kind of like a
little bit obvious but either way
whether it was obvious or not um I don't
know if it landed but I I was again
because I was so into the action I
didn't really care whether it landed for
me or not yeah I feel you but yeah know
I
mean if I mean if I'm a Hollywood
producer and I have an action film I'm
finding the stunt choreographer for this
film and the fight choreographer and I'm
making sure that they are I'm paying
them whatever they want and they're
going to work on my film
but like I said you can tell there's a
lot of inspiration like when I watch
Winter Soldiers Civil War definitely
dread uh Daredevil the Netflix uh show I
mean you can tell a lot they've clearly
the people who worked on that watch this
if if they didn't hire the people that
were already working on this they watch
that and like let's attempt to do this
as best we can because this is should be
the gold standard for how fight
choreography and action should be and
not only films in General but especially
if films here in the states I am curious
because it it just seems so much like it
was then we were in such closeup shots
and then such like VI visually um clear
wides that I feel like there's no way
that these were stunt doubles for any
shots and maybe that's why they were
able to do what they were able to do and
and not in some other movies or shows
that's that's a good point I mean I'm
sure it makes life so much easier when
you're coming up with these elaborate
fight choreograph scenes knowing that
all these actors can do what we need
them to do we don't need to put stunt
doubles or whatever in like unless they
did and I'm completely wrong but it did
not seem that way to me I'm with you it
really felt like all the ACT especially
the main ones too but it felt like all
the actors were doing their own stunts
and own fights um so yeah no I mean the
this is definitely one of the best
action just pure action it's one of the
best action films ever and again was so
tense like you never had a moment to
relax and chill it just continuously
kept on going like every every time you
felt like I'm getting a second it's like
no next one next one next one but they
did pause at really poignant moments
like even you're you're feeling like
okay it's been fight after fight after
fight that one hallway thing where we're
looking there's four people standing
down and he's like all right I know
what's coming right now it it it's nice
to have those moments or like when the
brother pulls them into the room and
they I think that they really carefully
picked those times to ramp up and when
to just let it breathe for a second so
that it didn't always feel one note yeah
no you make a great point they did and
they specifically picked uh scenes that
uh were really smart in terms of when
they did that because even in those
moments I still felt like the action
could be ramped up at any second I never
for a second felt CA relaxed for any
especially Rama and those character like
I always felt like they're always in
some type of danger or something crazy
is about to happen yeah so even when
when they have those moments that you're
talking about like just because again
they're specifically picking moments
where uh you know they're they're taking
a second to let us breathe for a second
and get some Exposition or a reveal
going you still always feel like action
can happen at any which time and you
never feel for a second that characters
are safe um do you have an action
sequence that stood out to
you obviously a lot for different
reasons but when you think about this
movie is there one you're going to
remember everything but I think
specifically if I'm thinking one it's
that two one fight the two brothers
versus I mean that's i' just in a box
yeah there was like nothing to distract
us um at the second he pulls the chain
up and you're realizing this is just a
square room with three men fighting till
one or two of them die I would have I
agree with you I would have thought that
they would have had Rama and him
oneon-one but if you think about like
think about all that Rama had been
through up until that point he's got to
be so worn down and tired at that point
from what he's survived through and
whereas that guy other than taking out
your man he really hasn't done too much
paddling so he's a lot more well rested
but still that scene even two onone I
also wouldn't have necessarily believed
that Rama was a better fighter solo even
if he wasn't exhausted than um the yo
mama I don't know what his name is the
little guy he is such a fierce fighter
and to see him take out my man we know
that he is and we describe the lore
around him going into this right he is
the number one he's the best fighter we
know he's better than Andy because when
we're talking about it that's what he's
described as Andy has a different
description this guy has that that lore
he can beat anybody yeah no I I agree
with you and also too he doesn't when
you just look at him you would not think
he's such an imposing fighter so like
the reveal of just seeing how good he
really is yeah disrespect of me
referring to him as the little guy
because I don't know his name I just
want you guys to know I think the best
things in small packages so I mean it
with all the honor in the world uh what
do we get a character name for him if we
did I don't remember I just I remember
Rama I remember Tama I remember jaku uh
jaka there we go exactly uh uh Andy yeah
and yeah the and then there's uh the ear
we called him ear guy we called him no
helmet guy then there's treacherous no
helmet guy yes why do you think that the
ear guy
lived um well I mean they got the bll
no it's just interesting that of all of
the characters
just like of all the people there's
three there's four people that live
total right uh Andy who stays and then
our three people which is dirty cop no
helmet wearing Rama and ear guy I think
they're like the writers are like we've
given this man enough pain and torture
we're going to let him have to live the
rest of his life with this I'm not just
saying this because he's my man but I
wish my man made it out I really do like
I feel like if you were gonna have if
you were because we know that there's
another one if you were gonna have not
if you were gonna have more than just
Rama make it out yeah I would have loved
to see Rama and it sounded to me like
when Rama was talking to Andy he said
I've been having to listen All Day to my
best friends talk about killing you and
I took that
as uh he's talking about my man as his
best friend they seemed like good cop
bad cop but they seemed like the two
coming into this so I would have lik to
see a sequel with that Dynamic of now
that guy learning that Rama and Andy and
again this was like amazing the way that
they did it but I am curious when they
were figuring out okay ear dudes got to
make it
through interesting choice no I mean
yeah you make a good point but I am
curious as the dynamic between uh jaka
and did I say that right this time yeah
okay good Jaa and Rama I'm curious is
their dynamic because I there was
tension too yeah yeah but also too
because at the beginning with no helmet
guy he was saying this is the team you
picked out a bunch of I think he said a
bunch of rookies and stuff so I am
curious he did describe him as his best
friends oh did he he when he was talking
to I know what you mean because he did
say this is a bunch of rookies but when
he was talking to Andy Rama said I
listen to my best friends that also
could be a translation thing no no
you're probably translation could have
meant to be like my colleagues I was
still processing so much information at
once but no you're probably right so um
I think also two as much as I would have
loved to have seen him survive I think
the whole
pointk I think the whole point of why
they did that was to show that no one is
safe obviously and also to like this man
is not to be trifled with he can take
out anyone yeah the stakes were very
high there did you want to see any
combat from um the Tama yeah I was
thinking that it's and it's fine you
said I was thinking I would have but I
mean but he was almost more menacing
that way right like that's not his role
he everybody are is henchmen I mean yeah
he's got people in place for that was
like the way he came off just where he
was really like silent about him and
just like more calm and then like he had
that moment where he exploded with Andy
like he scared the crap out of me from
that to the point where I don't really
need to see I mean if he would have fine
but I didn't need to see that it didn't
bother me that he wasn't in a hand toand
combat fight yeah I'm I'm with you I
think that it actually made for more
powerful everybody else was doing that
it's like when you have a script and
everybody's funny and you're like well
not everybody's funny you know some
people would be funny it's in this not
everybody's a fighter and he's the one
in charge of everything I understand
completely why this movie is as popular
as it is I was thinking that watching
this wow this makes perfect sense I get
why this is referenced on every action
list I guess I get why this is
referenced on a lot of foreign film
lists I get why all the film critics I
respect like this is the one this is if
you love combat this is what you need to
be
watching watching this I was thinking
maybe it was going to be overhyped for
me and then I was watching like yeah
they just they nailed it they
annihilated this movie I mean if I'm
ever making an action film I'm watching
this m like this is the gold standard we
got to be not so much to say copy this
but we got to be in line with this
whether it comes to the fight
choreography the editing the I mean just
everything was so on point when it comes
to action so yeah yeah I know for years
too I'd been hearing Craig had been
saying to me like you need to watch the
Raid I mean I got to itman which I loved
uh I did that here it was unbelievable
oh my God that one fight scene where
he's fighting like 10 10 guy oh my God
that scene I remember watching that for
the first time that's the one I had
heard about going into it yeah and then
this too now like oh my God and again
like i' I've said not to sound like a
broken record there's definitely you can
tell that there's been inspiration some
Hollywood films in terms of action uh
films that they have again inspired that
when I watch this I'm like oh I really
see this in that film and in that film
and in that film and I can understand
why I would want to try to emulate as
much as I possibly could without feeling
like I'm coping but just more of like
being respectful and we're going to
execute like they are doing here in this
film because that was just one of the
best not I'm not talking story just in
terms of pure action that's one of the
best action films I've ever seen in my
life yeah I hear you if this was an
American film I think that we would have
ended on Rama coming back to his
pregnant wife yeah and but we ended with
him saying goodbye to his brother did
you like the place that this ended or do
you wish that we got some kind of a
reunion I mean yeah I would have liked
him to uh to get back to his I mean we
know that he's going to get back to his
wife I think that would have been could
be a bumpy train ride we don't know yeah
but uh it's going to be interesting when
we do get to the sequel where I mean I I
got to assume Andy and Rah are both
going to be in it uh an ear dude we got
to see him back hopefully Jacka please
he's if anyone can survive a neck
breaking it's jock I why did I feel like
his eyes were gonna just pop open his
body's getting dragged I just wanted it
to be like Twitchy like a little bit I
don't know I was hope I really did like
his character a lot I mean he's a man of
honor and like I I really did love that
like again getting away from the action
I really did love that scene where he
stood up to no helmet guy I'm like uh
dude your ranking doesn't mean [__] like
we're gonna we're going to save guys I
don't care how insanely crazy it is like
you can either stay here or you follow
us I don't give a [__] logistically
speaking Yeah can a human survive their
neck getting
[Music]
snap this is a good question for let us
know let us know in the comments any
final burning words on the Raid
Redemption I I love this film so so much
uh again wasn't the deepest storyline
but I was so invested in the action that
I didn't care but again had a nice
little twist in terms of the the brother
reveal um I just again I've never seen
action quite like that it was really
exhilarating to watch the music the
cinematography the sound design I know
I'm stealing all your lines um but
seriously it it really was incredible to
watch it was
just I I just I can't believe that they
were able to accomplish this it's really
amazing I I wish Hollywood films could
do this consistently
um yeah there's a lot of great action
films too here in Hollywood um but
you're in Hollywood not quite to this
level well radi or not then that's the
end I'm usually a pun Queen I feel like
I really love you did good on this one
no I dropped the ball there's got to be
so many raid like
parade raid like your Trader I don't
know you you think
Ty yeah uh CR CR now you got you got to
think of a bunch now the Cradle to the
gra you got to think a much now for the
sequel okay time now well hopefully then
we get enough likes comments all that
stuff to get to the sequel uh let us
know if you think of anything puntier
than I just did and how you felt about
the raid I'm sure you guys have probably
seen it before because we're the last
two people on the planet to watch this
uh but you guys are the best thank you
reject and we'll see you next time
[Music]